Male Presenter: I want to welcome
Rana June today to Google New York.
Rana is known as the iPad DJ.
But we invited her here today because
her stories are so much deeper than that.
She started off as a developer
and through good decisions and risks
she's kind of evolved into
her current role as an iPad DJ.
She played TED a few nights ago
so we just thought it was a great
match to get out the geek crowd
and have her come down
and talk at Google.
So without further ado, Rana June.
Rana June: Thank you.
It's such a pleasure to be here
talking to you guys
because lately I play a lot of shows where,
it's like in a nightclub or whatever.
But really my roots are more on
the analytics and engineering side.
And, and, so I just want to tell you
a little bit about who I am
and I guess why I'm the iPad DJ
and maybe a professional DJ isn't.
So I grew up in Virginia and
Steve Case was my neighbor.
So I've been using kind of this new
generation of web if you will for,
for my whole life.
And my school, elementary school
actually beta tested AIM.
It was like really cool to see
how that whole community now,
the DC area is really, has created a lot
of the products that we use nowadays.
But I thought that
I wanted to go into politics.
And I went down that path
and I actually worked doing political lobbying
and grass roots stuff for a couple years.
And I realized very quickly
that that's not for me.
But if you could take those same principles
of getting communities together
and communications and really just gathering
people who are like-minded together,
if you applied that to business,
you could call that communications;
and suddenly now people aren't
so mad at you. [laughs]
And so I decided to kind
of shift roles a little bit.
And so I, I started a couple companies
and I realized that there was this amazing
opportunity to help entrepreneurs in the DC area
learn how to take their products to market.
Because there's all the AOL
layoffs were happening
and there were all these brilliant
engineers running around
with like 50,000 dollars in severance
and they all had ideas for start-ups.
And this was in the early 2000's.
And so people,
they just didn't know how to,
how to take those ideas and help other
people understand what they were building.
And I, I started this company
and I got like five clients in three weeks
or something like that.
And a few weeks later,
I basically got acquired
[laughs]
and so that was really
short-lived endeavor for me.
But I got a talent acquisition kind of thing
with a venture fund in New York, in DC I mean.
And so what happened was I was forced
to think about all these different verticals.
I was thrust into learning how to
take all those messages to market.
And it was 13 different companies
operating under a Keiretsu model.
So each company within our fund was basically
there to help support the other companies.
And I mean, I'm sitting here like,
oh, my God.
I know nothing about telecomm.
I know nothing about infrastructure.
I know nothing about any of these things.
But I had to learn.
So a few years later, fast forward to 2007
and the iPhone comes out.
And I am geeking out beyond belief
because I was like this is a--
this is a huge paradigm shift
and I was really excited about it and none of my
colleagues were really sharing that enthusiasm.
Except for one of my partners
and we were both kind of,
we had ja+ilbroken in our phones
and we realized there was this whole
development community forming
and that there was a great opportunity to build
a company around what was happening there;
so this kind of like just
an idea or whatever.
But then in, on June 1st, 2008,
we actually created the company.
We decided to leave the fund
and start this business
and 41 days later,
we'd actually built the product.
So on Day One of the App Stores launch,
we had a product in the market.
And so I have data from Day One about
application usage, patterns, behaviors,
all that stuff.
And again, coming
from an analytical background,
it's kind of the way my brain works,
I started to really understand
how people were gonna start incorporating
these devices into their daily lives.
And this is the first iteration;
at that point, it was the 3G.
But the 2nd version of the phone
so it was very early on;
so fast forward now a 1000 days later.
We have 10 billion application downloads.
So it's amazing to see
how quickly this has all changed.
But that book that's on your,
on your chairs right now
I decided last year to write a book
about the first 500 days of the
and kind of look back and see
what had happened prior to that
in terms of other people's attempts
to reach the mobile consumer
and sort of where those things had,
had fallen short.
And then also what Apple had done well
and tell stories of different developers and
former Apple employees and all of that.
So, I don't know if any of you guys know about
what the process for writing a book is.
But you submit it.
You work really hard
and then you submit it
and then you have to just basically sit around
and wait and that's really boring. [laughs]
So my background as a musician
is actually, it's-- it's not that new.
I was sort of playing music
when I was six and I played piano, violin.
Viola was my main instrument
and I was pretty good at viola.
And I picked up guitar at age 15.
And I also learned about
computer recording at 15
around the same time that I started
to get into electronic music.
So it was a really amazing
point of intersection there.
And so here I was,
I was in college.
And I was pretending to listen to lectures
but really I was making beats on my
math book or Power Book at the time.
And so when I built my career in business,
I'd always had a studio in my house
but it just never had an opportunity to
become something that I actually pursued.
And so I turned the book in and I thought,
Well, I have a few months now
where I don't really have much going on.
So why don't I just go to Guitar Center
and just buy a bunch of gear
and just get myself back up to speed
with what's going on in this space?
And so I went and I spent like 4000 bucks
buying midi-controllers and Ableton, Logic;
got all the tools, all the plug-ins.
And I sat down at my computer and I was like
what am I going to do with all this stuff?
It was really overwhelming just because
you have so many possibilities and it's just,
it can be a little bit cumbersome.
So that was really interesting time
because I had those little experiments
a week before the launch of the iPad.
So I was already kind of thinking
about music and how to,
how to take these new paradigms
and incorporate them.
And I was looking at things like the Lemur
which is a touch screen controller
and there were some really amazing things
happening with iPhones controlling laptops.
And so when I was sitting in line,
I actually, I live close by.
I went to the meat packing district
Apple Store at 2:00 in the morning
because [laughs] why not?
So I'm sitting there and
there's nobody else in line.
And I guess something just clicked
and I realized, Oh my God.
I can fuse what I know about mobile.
And I can fuse what I know about music.
And maybe there's something I can do in
the middle of those two passions of mine?"
So I raced home and the reason that I have
two iPads is actually also a funny story.
I had preordered my iPad and all
of my friends on Twitter were like,
"Steve Wozniak's in line with us".
"Everything's awesome."'
"Everyone's in line."
And I thought, "'Damn it.
I'm missing out. I gotta go."
So I like actually leapt out
of bed and went to sit in line.
So [laughs] now I had two iPads, right?
So I get home and I start kind
of messing around with them.
And I just, I discover
that there were,
there were some really incredible
instruments that had been built
that were specifically around the--
the notion of using a touch interface.
And the problem that I faced
at the time was that
I was using beta software or
maybe even alpha software.
All these apps had not been tested
on the actual device yet
because the developers at the time
didn't have, didn't have the access to,
to the iPad to test on.
So I had the buggiest,
worst experience and that's
why I incorporated the DJ mixer.
It wasn't originally my intention.
I actually just wanted to have two tablets.
And then I realized that this was actually
a real hindrance to my ability to perform.
So this is how, this is the genesis
of this set up.
And to give you a little bit of color
into what's happened since then,
I made a video and put it up on YouTube and
got almost a million views in two weeks.
So suddenly, this girl
who's like a data geek
is now the face of touch screen
mobile music making.
And I had to again learn very quickly
how to incorporate all the--
all of my background
and then also keep pushing
the boundaries of what's possible with,
with just two touch screen interfaces
and no computer as you can see.
I'm not; this is the processing
power that I have.
So these are my kids,
Alpha and Beta. [laughs]
And I hope with iPad 2 I don't
have the same problems but I,
I basically figured out a way to hack a version
of Ableton Live which is very popular,
it's called a 'Da'.
But in music, it's like an interface for
a lot DJ's use it for live performance.
And so what I've done is I've created,
like the set I'm going to play for you
probably took me about 30 hours to make.
It's not an easy process.
When I play shows that are 3 hours long,
it takes me weeks and months
to make the sets
because everything is done by hand
and it's, it's frustrating.
But I think that at this point,
I've played 90 shows since last April
for over 100,000 people and
every day I learn something new.
And again, coming back
to the beginning of the talk.
I mean I'm so excited to sit with you guys
because I really feel like everyone
in this room can help me
think about what the future of this is.
Because I think about this in the context of,
'Yeah, it's great.
I'm making music on an iPad.
But what does it really mean?'
Well, when I was a child,
playing music was my favorite
part of the day.
And my niece is 12.
And she doesn't have
a music program in her school.
So what if with a tablet, a child can learn
a chord progression on a piano.
Or they can learn rhythm
or they can learn music theory.
So if you can, if you can take this out beyond
just the fact that I'm an iPad DJ
which I didn't even name myself that.
I was actually given that name so it stuck.
But I kind of, I really think it's bigger
than just playing dance music.
And so I'm going to play a short set
for you guys.
And then afterwards feel free
to ask me questions.
And it's just really a pleasure to be here.
Thank you.
[applause]
Male Presenter: In about, I don't know
five or six minutes into the set,
if anyone wants to just queue up over here,
and we can kind of walk people over
here a little bit and escort them off,
and get another group.
For anyone who wants to get a closer look.
[music fades up] [music gets louder]
♪ Reached the city steps tonight, ♪
♪ Following the power lines, power lines, ♪
♪ Met a man bar side, ♪
♪ With eclipses for eyes. ♪
And you tell yourself, you don't let them touch.
Did I say too much?
Did I say enough?
I don't know Silvia,
I don't know, Silvia.
♪ [music]
Reached the city steps tonight.
Following the power lines,
Met a man bar side
With eclipses for eyes.
And you tell yourself
you won't let them touch.
Did I say too much?
Did I say enough?
I don't know.
Silvia.
Silvia. -via, -via, -via, -via
[rhythmic music]
Tell me lies.
♪ [rhythmic music]
Ah, ah, ah, ah, ooo,ooo,ooo
"We can fight our desires, ooo, ooo
But when we start making fires
We get ever so hot ooo, ooo
Whether we like it or not
They say we can love who we trust, ooo, ooo
But what is love without lust?
Two hearts and accurate devotion, ooo, ooo
What are feelings without emotion?
I'm goin' in for the kill,
I'm doin' it for a thrill,
I'm hopin' you'll understand
And not let go of my hand.
I'm goin' in for the kill,
I'm doin' it for a thrill,
I'm hopin' you'll understand
And not let go of my hand."
♪ [music]
I hang my hopes out on the line
Will they be ready for you in time?
If you leave them out too long, ooo, ooo
They'll be withered by the sun.
Full stops and exclamation marks, ooo, ooo,
My words stumble before I start.
How far can you send emotions?
Ooo, ooo.
Can this bridge cross the ocean?
We can fight our desires ooo, ooo
When we start making fires
We get ever so hot ooo, ooo
Whether we like it or not.
They say we can love
who we trust ooo, ooo
Oh, what is love without lust?
Two hearts and accurate devotion ooo, ooo
What are feelings without emotions?
I'm goin' in for the kill,
I'm doin' it for a thrill,
Oh, I'm hopin' you'll understand
And not let go of my hand.
I'm goin' in for the kill,
I'm doin' it for a thrill,
Oh, I'm hopin' you'll understand
And not let go of my hand.
♪ [music]
I'm goin' in for the kill,
I'm doin' it for a thrill,
Oh I'm hopin' you'll understand
And not let go of my hand.
I'm goin' in for the kill,
I'm doin' it for a thrill,
Oh I'm hopin' you'll understand
♪ And not let go of my hand. ♪
['hand' reverberates 50 times]
♪ [music]
♪ I need another story ♪
♪ Something to get off my chest ♪
♪ My life gets kinda boring, boring ♪
♪ Need something that I can confess ♪
♪ 'Til all my sleeves are stained red. ♪
♪ From all the truth that I've said, ♪
♪ Come by it honestly I swear. ♪
♪ Thought you saw me wink,
no I've been on the brink, so ♪
♪ Tell me what you want to hear ♪
♪ Something that were like those years ♪
♪ I'm sick of all the insincere ♪
♪ So I'm gonna give my secrets away. ♪
♪ This time don't need another perfect line, ♪
♪ Don't care if critics ever jump in line ♪
♪ I'm gonna give all my secrets away. ♪
[music crescendo]
♪ My God, amazing that we got this far ♪
♪ It's like we're chasing all those stars ♪
♪ Who's driving shiny big black cars? ♪
♪ And every day I see the news,
all the problems we could solve ♪
♪ And when a situation arises,
just write it into an album. ♪
♪ Seen it straight to go ♪
♪ But I don't really like my flow, no, so ♪
♪ Tell me what you want to hear, ♪
♪ Something that were like those years. ♪
♪ I'm sick of all the insincere ♪
♪ So I'm going to give all my secrets away. ♪
♪ This time don't need another perfect line. ♪
♪ Don't care if critics ever jump in line ♪
♪ I'm gonna give all my secrets away ♪
[music crescendo]
♪ Ooh, ♪
[music]
♪ tell me what you want to hear. ♪
♪ Tell me what you want to hear. ♪
[music]
♪ Tell me what you want ♪
♪ Tell me what you ♪
[music]
♪ Tell me what you want ♪
♪ tell me what you want to hear. ♪
♪ I'm gonna give all my secrets away. ♪
[music]
♪ What's the worst thing
that could happen to you? ♪
♪ Take a chance tonight
and try something new. ♪
♪ You're getting boring. ♪
♪ You're all so boring. ♪
♪ And I don't recognize
the zombie you've turned into. ♪
♪ Don't worry 'cause tonight I got you. ♪
♪ You can take a seat like you normally do. ♪
♪ I'm about to let you see ♪
♪ This is what'll happen
if you ain't giving your girl what she needs. ♪
["needs" repeat]
[music changes to techno beat]
[applause]
Male Presenter: Awesome.
So before I forget, I definitely want
to thank the great Google sound crew
for helping put all this together.
[applause]
Thanks to Kate Clouston for helping
put all this together as well.
So, I don't know if you want to talk
a little bit more or take some questions.
Rana June: Sure
Male Presenter: We definitely
have time for some questions.
Rana June: Awesome.
Well again, I mean, I'll be the first
to say that this wasn't perfect.
It has problems
but it's entertaining as hell.
So I think that's one of the things
that's really important to me as a musician
and kind of, I'm veering more into the--
the artist's realm now
than in the analytic space just nowadays.
And one thing that is really important to me is
when I see my favorite electronic musicians,
I'm like 'Dude are you checking
your e-mail right now
or are you playing music right now
because I can't really tell
and I think this really injects
a lot of creativity and an audio and
visual connection with an audience.
So I'm sure you guys can imagine like
when I play for 5 or 6,000 people, it's crazy.
Because I can like bring people up on stage
and I can swing the iPads around.
I can, you've never seen
a DJ pick up a turntable.
So this is definitely,
it's just, it's forcing people to think
about electronic music in a different way
because one of the things that makes
electronics so interesting for composers
is that you have unlimited
processing power, right?
Like the human mind can't do
as much as a computer can.
But what you lose is that now
you have a machine, right?
But if you have an organic touch manipulating
sound that's processed by a computer,
that's super exciting.
Especially for someone like me and--
and so I really hope this is the beginning.
And it hasn't even been a year
that I've been doing this.
So I hope when I come back and
play for you guys this time next year,
it'll be like crazy.
We'll have infrared and
we'll have like all this crazy stuff.
So I really welcome,
if you guys have questions, please.
Like I would love to talk to you guys.
Come.
There's the mic.
male #1: Do you sell your loops?
Rana June: Oh, that's a great question.
So, okay.
Well, you know, I'm in the company
of friends, right?
So here's what happened to me.
I started doing this and everyone's like, WTF?
And then they were like, no,
that's actually very cool.
So I have just been commissioned
for my first two remixes
and so I'm really kind of demonstrating
what I am doing as a producer
now a lot more than ever
and that's really what I am.
I'm a producer and DJ is not the right word.
But people, when you say, iPadDJ to anyone,
like walking around in Times Square,
they can understand what I'm doing.
And so it's really, like from a marketing
standpoint or whatever,
it gets me in the door a lot easier
than if I was like,
I'm a producer
who uses touch computer.'
I don't know,
like it doesn't make a lot of sense.
My mom understands
what an iPad DJ might be.
So I think as I start to do
a lot more production work
and people know what my sound is,
I have a really distinct sound , then
I will probably make my own app.
Because one of the things that's been
really tough for me and this is;
that's why it's a great question.
When I started doing this,
I made a decision on Day One that I wasn't,
even though I could just fire up X Code
and write something;
it's like I didn't want anyone to say
that I was using the iPad
because I was trying to sell something.
I really do believe in this platform.
I really do believe in what this means.
And so I wanted to just remove
that level of doubt.
So I only use apps that are available
in the App Store.
When I make my loops, when I do everything,
everything's only done on the, on the iPad.
It's all done with readily available software;
nothing proprietary.
However, as you guys can see,
it's kind of clunky for me.
I'm making this fit my work flow
and not the other way around.
And that's not ideal when you're a professional
entertainer or whatever and you're like,
Oh my God.
Is my thing gonna crash?
So I-- I just, now that so much time
has gone by,
I think it might be time for me
to start doing that
and of course, it will come preloaded
with loops and kind of.
I'll probably do tutorials about how I've
figured out how to make this work.
But that's the beauty of it, right?
If I hand this iPad to you with my set,
you'll probably figure out a different way
to perform it than I do
and that's what's so beautiful about it
'cause it's so personal.
But I mean it's just, it's, I'm kind of in this
strange position because people are like,
they find it hard to believe that I could
be the girl on the cover of that book
but then also the girl with red hair.
I mean, I think you guys probably
get that better than anybody.
I mean you can be creative
and technical at the same time
and it actually makes both sides better.
Does that answer your question?
Sorry.
Long answer.
male #2: So this is somewhat farfetched;
electronic music in the 70's and 80's
especially in Europe.
Musicians built a lot of their own instruments
because they didn't exist and
they didn't do what they wanted.
What do you think is missing from the
platform to enable people to do that?
Rana June: Knobs.
[laughter]
Seriously, I was praying.
I was watching the announcement
for iPad 2 and I was like,
Please be a USB port because if I could
have some element of hardware control,
like this mixer is, you guys see.
I don't touch it.
It's just here as a redundancy.
But I'm a big fan of circuit bending.
Like I've been, I've been messing with Speak
and Spell since I was a teenager.
That's so fun.
And that's the thing.
I listen to Alltecher.
I listen to Kraftwerk.
I love what those guys do that
is so unique and different
and I think the challenge here is that
you have Apple sandbox, right?
But if you look in the STK,
you'll see there are certain things that
you should technically be able to do
but you will get rejected
if you try and do that.
And I was saying like seven
or eight months ago
that there was definitely going
to be GarageBand on the iPad
because it just doesn't make sense
for them not to do it
considering what they were
withholding from developers.
But what I thought was
very surprising is that
like there are certain hardware
developers and manufacturers
that have created these amazing controllers
where you can put an iPhone inside a
keyboard or an iPad inside a keyboard.
And now the iPad or the iPhone
serves as the brain.
And it's just triggering midi
or whatever and that's great.
It's like moving in the right direction.
So when I can have a 49-key workstation
and it saves everything to my Garageband
session and I've got eight tracks going.
And then I can connect that or sync it
with my Logic Instance at home
and compose something on a plane
and finish it at home in the studio.
That's really cool.
We're just not there yet.
And so for me, that's, it's kind of like,
Oh my God.
I have five billion answers
to that question because it's,
I mean the most frustrating thing
about this to me
is that I know if I'm at home on
my tricked out Mac Book Pro,
the thing that I'm trying to do
that is taking me six hours,
literally six hours,
would take me like 3 1/2 minutes to do.
So those kinds of frustrations,
I think that's why you're not seeing
a lot of iPad DJ's out there.
Because it's really a frustrating
experience to even--
to just do the most rudimentary things and--
But like I said, it's a labor of love
because I really do think,
once everything catches up with
what you can do on a laptop,
this will be so much more valuable
than that experience will be.
male #3: So to follow that up,
we might have some Android developers here
interested in what's missing from that.
Rana June: Show yourselves.
[laughs]
male #3: But outside of that
as a follow-up question to,
when you were talking earlier
about your workflow,
getting to watch how you work,
it seems like there's almost
no real need for the DJ mixer.
You don't use the DJ mixer.
You just use it to sum the two outputs
more than anything?
Rana June: Yes.
male #3: Okay.
So everything's happening on the iPads.
You don't use the DJ mixer
as a DJ mixer at all.
Rana June: Exactly.
However, it's one of those things
where it's like life insurance.
You keep paying every month
and you're like,
why am I paying for this?
Health insurance, better example.
That's how I feel about it because I did
my thing at TED and oh my God.
What just happened?
My effects aren't working.
I'm touching the chaos pad and it's not doing
anything and I'm messing up all my transitions.
The audience doesn't know.
I know.
I had to just literally be like,
'I'm gonna reboot this now.
Let me just make it look
like I'm doing something'.
But that's really sucky.
So I'd like to, when I do
the more high pressure shows,
I'll just put my, this sounds crazy
but I think you guys will understand.
Like why I do this.
I'll have an iPhone or something
or like an iPad touch
and I'll just randomly play music at 128
beats per minute on a loop, whatever.
And I don't even care what it is.
But in the event that I might need,
if everything just dies,
and I just need something just to be playing,
I try to do that when I know
that there's the potential
for that kind of catastrophic failure.
But its things like that.
I mean my problems are so different
than other people's problems.
Like, I'll tell you guys an anecdote
that sucked so bad.
I played a huge show for a big client of mine
and it was like their holiday party, right?
So it was all their advertising
clients were there.
And I mean they had blown it out.
It was in L.A.
at this huge venue and
I'd had a really lovely day.
I had gotten a massage that day
and I was just chillin' in L.A.
and the 70 degree weather
got to me in December.
And I get to my sound check like super late.
I normally do my sound check early
in the day just in case. [laughs]
And so I get there and
I checked everything else:
I checked power,
I checked the cables.
I didn't turn my iPads on until like maybe
15 minutes before the show started.
So I go and load my Looptastic.
The provisioning license expired.
[audience members chuckle]
I'm like, Oh, my God.
So here I am in Xcode trying to fix it.
I'm calling the developer who's three hours
in different time zone than me.
It's like ten minutes, five minutes
before the show
and I'm like, Dude you gotta fix this.
I'm freaking out.
And it got resolved like a minute
before the doors opened
but I mean these kinds of frustrations you
just don't anticipate and that's the problem.
If you could read a book about
what touring musicians experience,
none of my challenges are in there.
So it -- [laughs]
I've learned a lot.
It's really tested me.
The fact that I am still doing it
is insane to be honest.
But that's kind of,
I just, it's comfortable.
I'm familiar and that's the only thing
that I have control over right now
is that I can get this mixer everywhere I go.
And so it just helps me understand
what I'm doing.
That's the other thing too.
Because these are, I try;
I practice like five hours a day total.
Not just physically performing
but making stuff.
I treat it like an instrument, right?
So I'm constantly importing new songs or
whatever and doing all this stuff with it
and like I have six iPads right now
that are all kind of synched.
It's like okay, so there's
a lot of movement there.
The reason that I use the DJ M or whatever,
a five channel mixer is that like when I do
shows that are longer than an hour,
I need to have four iPads.
And I was explaining earlier like
when I do three hour shows,
sometimes I'll have all six plugged
in ready to go.
And then just helps.
It just helps.
male #4: I have a couple of questions.
Well, actually one question.
A couple of comments.
First of all, I sort of feel like
it's not truly mobile
unless you don't have wires
attached to your gadgets.
So have you considered Bluetooth
Audio for your setup?
Rana June: Bluetooth synched right now
which is already for me like a huge gamble.
I tried;
that was the thing.
I'm with you.
Look.
I mean I can roll into my gig
with these in my purse.
Like that's how mobile it is on that end.
But I do have to deal with this.
So I think it's one of those things where,
at first what I tried to do was get a third iPad
with there's an app that's really gorgeous,
Controls Surface.
I tried doing it all.
It just sucks.
It's not there yet.
Maybe, maybe iPad 2 will solve
some of those audio problems.
But for me, I couldn't get it.
There was so much latency involved
when I was doing things with Bluetooth
or using wireless of any kind.
With this,
this is so blasphemous anyways guys.
Sometimes some of my shows,
are there any audio geeks in here?
Really, the DJ gods are
like frowning on me so much
because I have an eighth inch
cable to an XLR.
It's so wrong.
And that's kind of the other thing.
I mean it's not like this is good audio signal
but at least it's reliable.
So if you know of any way that
I can make that work without wires,
I would be totally down.
male #4: Actually I figured you would say you
don't have a good answer for that question.
Rana June: [laughs]
male #4: [laughs] Anyway,
I can't resist a shameless plug here.
Rana June: Yeah.
male #4: So I recently thought up
a media Bluetooth interface
that would be a way for your knobs
to talk to your gadgets.
Rana June: That's such a--
that's such a problem for me.
You guys see.
Sometimes I'll miss something.
I'll literally have to loop back 16 bars because
I couldn't move my fingers fast enough.
Or it says 16 inputs for multi-touch.
It doesn't mean it actually works for 16.
I don't have 16 fingers anyways.
But it's like, if I do four or five things
at a time, things get screwed up.
So having a physical controller
would be awesome.
male #4: You may hack me soon
though because it works.
It works with Android
and unfortunately Steve Jobs may not
let you access the API that you need.
Rana June: Do you know what?
Look.
I'll say this no matter where I am.
If I could do this on whatever,
whatever, I would do it.
It just so happens that right now
this is what's working.
I'm really open to ideas here
because that's the thing.
I'm getting to the point
where I'm trying to get a little stuck.
'Cause there's certain things
that I just can't do.
So that's the thing you know.
I'm really, really open.
Maybe I'll incorporate one Android tablet.
And I'll have three or maybe,
I'm sure that there's things I can do.
It's just a matter of getting that to work.
Thank you guys, I appreciate it.
[applause]
00:47:50.633,00:00:00.000